hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
guiding pancreatic cancer therapy
by individualized epigenetics i'm alexis
krause of lapperts
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by agilent for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
agilent.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left ear screen
i will now turn it over to dr valentina
maron
to introduce our speaker and our
presentation for today
thank you for the introduction i am
valentina marana global product manager
for microarrays at agilent
today i'm happy to present a great work
performed
by dr surajidara senior research
scientist at the dharmud ichiko
norris cotton cancer center so
thordara's team have developed an
individualized
epigenetic tool to help guide pancreatic
cancer therapy
through the analysis of individualized
epigenetics
this is a great example of what can be
achieved
thanks to the customization capabilities
of our microarray platform
now i leave the microphone to draw
thanks valentina for your kind words
and i am suraj dhara i am the co-founder
and president of
episteme prognostics which is a
precision
medicine company a spin-off from
mskcc new york and darmud norriskan
cancer center
in new hampshire so what we do
we we try to guide pancreatic cancer
therapy by individualized epigenetics
and i will take you through
our work which we recently
accomplished
first slide so we focused pancreatic
ductal adrenal carcinoma which is the
most
lethal form of pancreatic cancer and
pancreatic cancer is one of the most
lethal malignancies
known till date and this is
projected to be the second largest cause
of cancer related
death in the united states by 2030.
there are over 57 000 new cases in the
united states
and half a million worldwide recorded
in the in 2020 and these numbers
are rising fast
so what happens in clinic
so this is the standard protocol in a
pedagog clinic
any patient comes with a suspected
malignancy
the radio diagnosed followed by
biopsy confirmation of the lesion and
then
stratified to three groups
resectable borderline respectable and
non-respectable
for therapeutic intervention
the resectable group they
they qualify for affront surgery
followed by an adjuvant chemotherapy
the borderline resectable group they
first undergo a neoadjuvant chemotherapy
to downstage the tumor followed by
surgery
and the non-resectable group they only
get chemotherapy no surgery is involved
in this group
so what we can see in the best case
scenario is about 20
20 to 30 response
when i say response meaning long-term
response
long-term survival disease free for more
than five years
as shown in this cartoon that resected
tumors
are resected patients that
the primary tumor is completely resected
by a process called
ripple as shown in this cartoon on the
left side of the
of the slide and the kaplan mayor graph
that shows what we see
in the clinic after follow-up
so as you can see here in this graph
that post resection all patients are
apparently disease free
and they were put put on two adjuvant
chemotherapies
green the the blue line is gem cytobin
and the red line shows fall 5 knocks two
different
chemo chemotherapy and as time
progresses
in x-axis you can follow within a year
you see a significantly large number of
patients close to half they relapse
some more patient relapse within
42 months or or around 42 months
but this 20 to 20 to 30 percent patient
at the right side end of the scapular
mare they live
for more than five years disease free
so the take home is virtually all
patients are treated
with either fault firing oxogen cytobin
in in pancreatic cancer and
which does not include any molecular
markers
predicting response and the result that
we can see
is 20 70 to 80 percent patient
relapse unfortunately
so we hypothesized we wanted to
understand
the nuances so we hypothesized
epigenetic differences at the level of
chromatin
accessibility which potentially linked
to distinct differentiation states
might distinguish rapidly recurring from
non-recurring tumor
and i'm gonna explain that soon
so before that first rationalize
why epigenetics
because number one epigenetics
correlates
with phenotypes with genetic mutations
do not explain
for instance 37 trillion cells of
our body they share identical genome
identical dna sequence but they have it
has been
proved that they are genetically
different
all biological aspects has been
correlated
well with epigenetic patterns
number two is it is robust unlike
gene expression signature you can
you can avoid the rna related
tissue rna degradation issues
and third is epigenetic reprogramming
has an enormous potential i can
talk about it day long but
it it has it it has its powerful
impression
in the health sciences field from
regenerative medicine to cancer
so considering these three facts
we thought to understand the
nuances of outcome of pdac
in the light of epigenetics
the second rational is why chromatin
accessibility
chromatin accessibility summarizes
all known upstream epigenetic mechanisms
for instance
10 years before we knew epigenetics
means dna methylation
but now we know epigenetics is more than
that
epigenetics encompasses dna methylation
histone modification
and chromatin remodeling so we finally
all the mechanisms upstream leads to
a right balance maintaining a right
balance of open and close
chromatin
so now with this background information
i'm taking you through our experimental
details how we accomplished
our goal so we tested
our hypothesis by investigating tumor
intrinsic
chromatin accessibility landscape of
pdag
because the first challenge that we
encounter
is tumor micro environment is
notoriously heterogeneous
like all other tumor pdac is also
notoriously heterogeneous it has
epithelial malignant epithelial cells
fibroblast cells
endothelial cells and other cells
and influ infiltrated immune cells
one more thing as depicted in figure b
which is unique to p dac
if you take a resected piece of tissue
from pediatric tumor
the epithelial cellularity notoriously
values
you may not get a single cell in that
versus 90
of the tissue will be full of
epithelial cells so we wanted to
see the tumor cell intrinsic
epigenetic pattern in in this pedagogue
tumors
so what we did we tried to
physically isolate the malignant
epithelial cells
by epithelial cell addition molecule
conjugated magnetic beads which is
simply simpler
to isolate and as it shown in this
cartoon
that we have we have isolated if
epithelially it can
positive and it can negative
cells from the resected tumors and then
we compare these two subpopulations to
make sure that we have enriched tumor
population by
keras mutant little frequency enrichment
and micro analysis gene expression
analysis between these two
sub populations as shown in the lower
panel c
and d and after we are sure
that our enrichment is satisfactory we
went ahead
and did attack sequencing on epcam
positive subpopulation of pedagog tumors
we we sampled
replicate samples from every tumor how
any piece of tumor that we get we
allocated into two
and then independently process them
transposition reactions and all other
reactions are independently done
so although they were not biologic
replica in every tumor but they are not
technical replica either
so they are like in between biology
replica and technical replica
just to make sure just to be very sure
about what we discover is correct
so what we did is every patient each and
every patient
two replica as shown in figure a are
are plotted like in x and y axis and we
took the overlapping peaks
and this first panel on the left side
shows
like lot of satisfactory overlapping
peaks in the dark
black region while the left side panel
shows a very little tiny little black
region that means
this particular patient did not we
didn't retrieve
many reproducible peaks
maybe because of our technical artifact
so what we did we took the best quality
libraries selected by this is called idr
irreproducible discovery rate selected
by idea so
we took the best quality 40 patients
library
for our discovery set analysis and
we tested if 40 patients are good enough
to cover the entire pathway of open
chromatin peaks
in human pancreatic duct carcinoma
so as you can see it nearly reached to
saturation
that means we have discovered this
thousand six 120 and ninety seven open
chromatin peaks
from forty feeder patients
and if we increase say up to four
hundred extrapolate
we may have included some more peaks
but that is that may not be worth
however with this entire human pdac
reference epigenome we
we identified a specific signature
a 1092 regions which were represented
differentially between recurring group
of patients and non-recurrent group of
patients as shown
in the figure c
so in this figure
you see the red regions on the top are
300 regions which are open
in patient were recurrent and 700
regions in the bottom
the green green slab region which are
silenced
in these patients so for instance this
is one of the example
tasks 3 promoter tumor suppressor
candida gene 3 promoter region
as as depicted for an instance
now this particular promoter is silenced
in recurrent patients
the red tracks on top shows the
the the uh genomic track retrieved from
the record
recurrent patients and the blue track
shows
the same from non-recurrent patients and
the lower panel
here is encode defined task 3 promoter
region
as you can see in hpd e6 at the bottom
that task 3 promoter is open which is a
normal pancreatic
cell line whereas in aggressive
pancreatic cancer the task 3 region the
same region here
is silenced close which is further
corroborated
by uh dna methylation profile this is
encode
data now we overlapped with an encode
data with
with our our data in the same region as
you can
as you can appreciate that almost
all red tracks this particular region
tattoo promoter region
is silenced whereas the blue region here
almost all patients this region is
opened
not silenced and we have
1092 such regions in the genome that you
discover
are represented differentially between
patients who recur versus patients who
did not record
then we found the thought so this open
and closed regions
whether they represent what
transcription factor or regulatory
elements
the what transcription factors they bind
to their regulatory elements
and we discovered through a motif search
that
61 transcription factors which
represent differentially between patient
to record
which is which is shown in the
top red panel in figure a
and and the motifs which represent
in non-recurrent patients which is
represented in blue
and then we further confirmed with
immune histochemistry the top hits
hnf1 and zika scan as shown in figure b
as you can see here in figure b in
indirectly representative recurrent
patient
hnf nuclear localization of hna is
completely abolished
whereas in a non-recurrent patient very
starkly contrasting green dots you can
see in the nuclei
and the zika scan showed an opposite
trend
and with hnf alone you can segregate
patterns based on their
disease free survival then we went ahead
and validated this results to
another completely independent cohort of
97 pdac
tumor uh tissue
microarrays where 45 patients
were on cyber believed their overall
survival was less than six months
whereas
52 patients the long survivors they
lived over
six years as an overall survival and you
can appreciate for this
figure in figure d that
in all short-term survivors the
nuclear localization of hna is
completely gone
completely absent but
you can see sharp dots red dots
in the nuclei of long-term survivors
and you can see them in the quantity
quantitatively in figure e
so after this validation we went ahead
and thought that well our
invention our discovery rather our
discovery of this 1092 signature
extrapolated to that clinical diagnosis
but a toxic being a cumbersome expensive
method
and we really reason that this chance of
its translation into clinic everything
will be difficult
so we invented ata array
the only microarray that reads chromatin
accessibility
so now this is a busy slide i'll take
you through our through our invention
what we did is a very simple way
but very effective and robust
method of reading chromatin
accessibility
so what we what we reasoned that
if we print the differential regions on
a glass line
on a microarray as shown in this in this
room the left side red group of
humanoids are recurrent group of patient
the blue non-recurrent group of patients
and they have
signature which is depicted here simply
that
red block red block here are 300
regions which are differentially open in
recurrent fashion
whereas the blue regions are silenced
and vice versa opposite and the green
regions
are in both the groups as
positive controls so if we have a
we have an intact library made from
this group of patients the red group of
patients or recurring
patients the red region in the
id will be predominantly amplified
whereas the blue regions since they're
silenced in these patients
they will not be represented
and the opposite profile you could
expect from an impact library of a blue
group of patients or non-current group
of patients
so now if we hybridize these libraries
with the microarray we get these
differential profiles as shown in the
bottom two
figures in the left side
see the red peak here is shifted to the
right
of the blue peak as we expect
it would be because the red region
here is predominant so intensity comes
from coming from red regions
are more than blue regions and
green as a positive control the most
intense regions and the black peak here
is a negative control provided by
agilent as cg
backbone of the microarray so that's
what you would expect
and the exactly opposite profile you can
see from a patient
who were non-recurrent so these two are
the real data from two
to real patients and we
we found that within these 932
regions which was covered by agilent
probes out of 1092 regions
they remarkably correlated with a tactic
confined to these regions and that
was really remarkable correlation
so in other words attack array
does the job of attack's sake
but in a lot convenient
way and you can read any you can print
any signature and conveniently read
on a tag array and also
we we we i peed our
candidate motives including hnf
so now we developed
a a combined combined
uh tool called panc epistem dx
which is actually combination of the
prognostic
prognosis score derived from our attack
array and the nuclear localization
patterns
of hnf so together
we could decipher the nuances of
pdac and we see that
it did segregate patients into different
significantly different dfs groups
as shown in b figure b
which is attack array alone could
segregate them into two groups
and when you compare when you combine
attack array
with the hnf so calling it pancake stem
dx
our segregation is way more confident
and we could segregate these patients
into four distinct
groups and we also validated
in an organoid cohort which is shown in
figure d so
tag epistem dx works works beautifully
so now the value of this
pancake step dx is if we include if we
can include them in a current
clinical diagnostic procedure so
if patient comes as they
normally get get radio diagnosed and
biopsy diagnosed
at the clinic for suspected malignancy
if we include
pancake stem dx in the whole process
and that and we get result in three days
so that that means we can utilize the
time window of our standard diagnostic
process
and at the end the oncologist will know
if a patient carries a good prognosis or
a bad prognosis signature
if a patient is a front resectable
but carrying a good prognosis signature
they can straightway go for a
front surgery and adjuvant chemotherapy
their chance of long-term response
becomes 100 percent
whereas a patient although
qualifies for surgery but having a bad
prognosis
now we know these patients are the ones
who are going to relapse
if we follow this adjuvant path
so we can think of an alternate therapy
for them
either by new adjuvant path right at
this moment this is
currently a big deal to take a decision
between actual versus new adjuvant path
for
pdac patients and also we can
combine and epigenetic drugs
and in in few slides i'll explain why
epigenetic drugs because our profile is
epigenetic profile
so the value proposition that we have
is oncologists can better stratify the
therapy
and also with epigenetic drugs we can
develop companion diagnostics
with pancreas mdx so now
i suggest why we can propose an
epigenetic therapy and
tailored epigenetic therapy to pdac
patients who have poor prognosis
signature
and this is a hypothetical it has to be
tested but this is a pretty testable
hypothesis
so this is a snapshot of our signature
and two of them i already explained task
3 and hnf
and we now recently known that hnf
silencing is done by enhancer of gesture
hemolog 2
is a component of polycom repressure
complex
so now we know easy h2 silenced
hnf so there are many
drugs available at this moment
which we could utilize to reprogram the
epigenome
so this is a hypothetical scenario so if
we have a patient with a bad signature
as shown in the upper panel
of this cartoon the patient refractory
to chemotherapeutic agent will have
a profile like that the red peak will be
shifted to the right of the blue
so if we give an epigenetic drugs
such as hdac inhibitor or test metrostat
like easyhd inhibitor or so on what we
could expect
is opening up of the silencing silenced
regions
and the intensity will move to right on
top of the
red peak and we can expect
a better response because we have
reprogrammed the epigenome
whereas a patient who already have a
good pregnancy signature if we know
beforehand
not first of all you do not need to give
them
an epigenetic drug they are already good
they are 100 percent sure that respond
they will leave for more than five years
disease free
so we may we may not give them we if we
give
we may not increase their chances of
response to chemotherapy however
this is a testable hypothesis that we
are testing it through
a proper uh pathway as shown in the
lower panel
till clinical trial
so we have right now nine epigenetic
drugs
and many more in the pharma pipeline for
us to develop companion diagnostics with
pancake piston dx so
so the summer to summarize is the last
slide i believe
to summarize our episteme development
pipeline
is number one we are developing
it from an invention of an academic lab
to a cancer diagnostic kit in hospitals
so that all hospitals and
that laboratories can can use it
for their routine clinical
stratification
we are optimizing all different aspects
of benchmark measures of the attack
array
and testing its feasibility in liquid
biopsies
and also number two as i explained we
are also planning to develop companion
diagnostics with
epigenetic drugs through a
formal path from cell line to clinical
trials
although our main focus has been
pancreatic
cancer but of course potentially it is
applicable to other indications as well
but it's long way to go again
and with this i conclude my today's
presentation
and acknowledge the team first of all i
apologize
for the names where which are not
included here
because there are many people who are
directly or indirectly involved
to accomplish this project to bring this
project a success
but the names here which were directly
interacted with
and the man like author author in the
author list
of the manuscript so it involves
multiple institutions
and and agilent technologies
of course without them would have not
been possible
and also i thank agilent for giving me
this podium
and i thank you alexis for conducting
all this from labruz site and
and thank you labrut for
for for doing this it's a disclosure to
give right now agilent products are not
for risk or not
for diagnostic procedures their research
use only
and that's it and that's that's all i
have for today's presentation
if you have any question i'll be happy
to thank
um i i realized that
uh although i mentioned in the beginning
that
uh episteme prognostics is the spin-off
from mskcc and darmud
but this is the formal disclosure which
says most of the research work was done
in mskcc dharmus and the other
collaborative institutes
under the leadership of professor steven
delete
he was the former inaugural director of
david m robest in pancreatic cancer
center
memorial's loan carrying cancer center
and currently the director
of the dharmathic norris scotland cancer
center
and steve is also the co-founder of
episteme prognostics
and also i would like to
especially thank valentina maran
and carol koch for helping me
while preparing for this webinar thank
you carol thank you valentina
and i now i can i can ready to take all
the questions that you have
thank you thank you so much dr dara for
your informative presentation
so we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started dr dara
our first question how is the atac
array advantageous over atac seek
alright so so so first of all
first of all these are two different
technologies
we are not we are not competing with a
taxi
a taxi is more of a discovery tool
when you want to know the de novo new
discovery of a signature but once you
discovered a signature like our 1092
signature
and you want to employ it in a
diagnostic purposes
then attack array is
simpler faster cheaper than it doing a
taxi
so that's that's how a micro advantage
of microwave could be
could be leveraged
wonderful thank you so much for that
clarification
so dr dara moving on to our next
question um
a little similar to our first one which
is how are epigenetic signatures
advantageous over gene expression
signatures
well so this is like a
it's a good question first of all so
the we know that now
through all these international
consortiums in last decade
most of the malignant diseases
have been subclassified into molecular
subtypes
and which means that their gene
expression signatures differ differ
from each other with different
prognostic groups but the problem is
these signatures gene expression
signatures often
comprise of multiple genes
which that means if you have a specific
pattern of of a gene expression
in a typical poor prognosis patient
technically you should be completely
reprogrammed them
and it is virtually impossible to target
all the genes
whereas if you see an epigenetic
signature
the collective reprogramming of the
regulatory element by an epigenetic drug
is possible so so for in our
case network has just explained
700 regions were silenced in a in nap
genome of a poor prognosis patient
it could be possibly could be opened up
by
one or two drugs like as gh hdac inhibit
inhibitor
or phase meter stat that i explained
that's how
the collective reprogram reprogramming
opportunity
it gives that is why it is more
advantageous than gene expression
signatures wonderful
so dr dara is the 1092
chromatin signature casual to
chemotherapy response
in pdac well that
part we are testing at this moment as i
showed through hypothetical
uh cartoon slides that if
if they were causal then we could
if we open them then they would be
making
the tumors amenable to chemotherapy and
if they do then he has their causal
wonderful so just as a reminder
to our audience i thought those
questions that we are unable to answer
today and those that come in during the
on-demand period
will be answered by the speaker via the
email address that you provided at the
time of registration
so please continue to input your
questions um
for dr dar today so moving on to our
next one
dr daryl will it be possible to apply
the same array
and or approach to a different cancer
type
yes of course so two two ways you could
be
you could be doing it number one is
testing
how many of among this 1092 overlap with
other
other tumor types or you can have a
complete
discovery of cancer-specific signatures
by
a taxi the way we did it by in pdac and
then
print that signature to attack array for
diagnostic purposes
so yes it is extrapolated extraordinary
it can be extrapolated
thank you so much and looks like we've
got
one more question for you so dr dara
how can we access this technology
so one of the one of the
uh business strategy that epistem right
now
we are thinking is a paper service
is one of the in addition to developing
it as a kit you know in addition to
developing a pistol
dx as a companion diagnostics we
also do paper service if you're
interested to
get the profiles done by techrey we can
do it for you
we are commercializing this technology
perfect and it looks like we've got
another question
that popped into here for us so how long
uh oh here it is how long do you think
it will
take for these technologies to be
included in diagnostic procedures
so this is actually it has to be
done through a clinical studies
correlative clinical studies
so follow-up of at least three years so
overall
it will take three to four years to
actually bring it
to the fda approved 510k approved
diagnostic
kit
okay perfect thank you so much for
answering that
so uh we still have time for a couple
more questions so if any audience
members want to
submit their questions it's in the far
left hand side of your studio
more than welcome to submit questions to
dr dara
but do you um while we're waiting for
some questions to come in dr dara do you
have any final comments for our audience
uh not not
really and i just
all that i wanted to tell you is thank
you all for attending
this uh webinar and
please feel free to write me an email as
displayed in my
email address episode prognostics.com
i'll be happy to answer your questions
perfect thank you so much dart dr dara
so looks like that is all the time we
have
for today but before we go i would like
to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions
as a reminder questions that we did not
have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by dr jara via
the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration we would
like to once again thank dr zara
and also dr moran for their time today
and their important research
we'd also like to thank leopards and our
sponsor agilent for underwriting today's
educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
that's all for now thank you so much
everyone for joining us
and until next time bye-bye
thank you f6 bye